All right, today we are going to be speaking
with senior adviser for the Joe Biden for
president campaign, Cristobal Alex, who has
worked on you've been working on campaigns
for a long time.
I mean, you're not new to this.
That's right.
I'm I'm a bit of an old timer.
You can tell from my grades.
I've had a couple of these campaigns behind
me, Maria, though, they called me and the
campaign.
So let's I want to talk let's start maybe
by talking about the Latino vote.
I've been speaking on my show, but also with
my audience over on my Spanish language show
on the Australia Network about the Latino
vote and the growing importance demographically
of the Latino vote in the United States.
I was slightly disappointed, but not altogether
surprised that a higher share of the Latino
vote did not go to Joe Biden.
Now, I know that there's a number of ways
that we could spin this.
We could look at specific states.
We could look at sort of the range of of the
vote of the Latino vote that typically goes
to the Republican candidate.
And certainly what Donald Trump got is within
that range.
But is there any disappointment on your side
that it was not an even more overwhelming
victory for Joe Biden among that group?
You know, I'll say that we're very proud of
the work of the campaign and all of the work
that preceded the campaign in critical battleground
states around the country, decades of organizing
work from young people, from immigration rights
organizations to Puerto Rican organizations
to others that have led to this election,
which I think is a an important moment if
you look at the trajectory of building Latino
political power.
I think we're approaching a high watermark.
And yes, the Latino community is, as you know
better than anybody is, is not a monolith.
And so we do want to look more specifically
at data from states or even within states.
And when we set out in the general election
with our Latino program, we set a goal to
match the high watermark of the 2012 Obama
Biden reelection campaign that hit seventy
one percent of the Latino vote.
We are just about there as far as the numbers
are calculated and tabulated.
We're at about seventy, seventy one percent
range right now in some of the more crucial
battleground states that's nationally.
If you look at some of them, if you drill
down a little bit, you look at a place like
Wisconsin, for example, where we had a hundred
thousand plus Latino vote turnout in those
places.
Latinos really exceeded that, hitting almost
80 percent.
If you look at Maricopa County, we flipped
Arizona and Pima County, you're looking at
over 80 percent, some places.
Eighty five percent of the of the vote.
It's also the reason why we kept we flip to
Arizona.
That's why we kept Nevada.
That's why we elected a United States senator,
Latino United States senator in New Mexico.
And if you look at Pennsylvania, a huge surge
of Latino voters, a lot of what a lot of Puerto
Ricans there.
And again, because of the hard work that preceded
the campaign and proudly, I will say, because
of the campaign's significant investments,
over one hundred million dollars to reach
Latino voters, we exceeded almost that 80
percent mark in Pennsylvania, again, proving
to be the margin of difference.
We're very excited about that.
Yeah, OK, good.
So those are some good examples.
I mean, let's let's now talk about one that's
an area of concern to me.
We've known for a long time that while the
American Latino voter community is not a monolith,
one of the it is a very left community in
total, with the notable exception of Cuban-Americans.
And we know about this sort of anti Castro
reflexive thing and fears of so-called socialism,
which will often influence particularly Florida
Cuban-Americans to vote at higher levels for
Republicans than than we see in other states.
It would be huge, would it not, to be able
to bring over more of that Cuban-American
community in Florida?
Because without Florida, the map for Republican
Republicans nationally gets systemically very,
very difficult.
And I'm wondering what you think it will take
to bring over more Cuban-American voters?
That's a great question.
I'll start by saying Miami Dade and South
Florida, a true battleground.
And we we fought very hard and competed for
every single voter there.
And we did win by a good margin, the Latino
vote in Florida.
We've got some work to do with with Cubans
and also Venezuelans and others.
And if you look a little deeper, I think President
elect did very well with younger voters, young
Latino voters, especially.
Those were very high vote share for us.
But we've got some work to do.
It was some of the older voters, especially
the Cuban voters.
And I'll say it's hard to compare this election
to 2016 when Secretary Clinton got a lot of
support from the Cuban community.
Part of the reason for that was, if you remember,
the presidential primary in 2016.
On the Republican side, Donald Trump spent
a lot of time attacking Marco Rubio, for example,
among other things, that that brought down
his percentage among Cuban voters.
But as you pointed out, that usually a higher
percent goes Republican there.
So we are going to do some work there.
And I think part of it we'll see trending
in our direction very soon is once President
elect Joe Biden and takes office along with
his vice president, Kamala Harris, we're going
to do a lot of work to make sure that we can
expand democracy in Cuba.
Then we strengthen relationships throughout
Latin and Central America and make sure that
we're doing the things that we need to do
that will eventually again, this is going
to be a good policy, but eventually will yield
a better percentages.
And some of the.
These communities, when we look at the politics
of it, yeah, you mentioned that this year
Donald Trump was not attacking Marco Rubio
in the way that he was in 2016.
One of the other differences I noticed, and
I wonder if you if you think this is relevant
electorally, is that merely by chance?
Not because Donald Trump's views have become
more enlightened, but merely by chance.
There was much less discussion about Mexican
rapists and criminals in the last six months.
There was much less discussion about the wall,
although at rallies, Trump would say the wall
is being built in Mexico.
Mexico's paying for it, obviously, both wise
by by sheer distraction, it seems, from what's
been going on.
Trump did less of that.
And I'm wondering if that also ended up helping
him a little bit in the end.
Yeah, that's a great question.
I wonder that myself and I did expect a lot
more of the typical vitriol demagoguing Latino
communities, especially immigrants.
And it was there no doubt, just not on the
front page or the first thing out of his mouth
that we would see in twenty eighteen or twenty
sixteen.
Right.
Part of the reason for that is undoubtedly
the fact that our country is facing a pandemic
and the economy is is is in bad shape again
because of Donald Trump's failed leadership.
And that was top of mind for voters.
And he tried very hard, no doubt, to to try
and make the election anything about himself
or his failed leadership.
But at the end, it becomes a referendum on
his handling of covid is complete and utter
failure there.
And so it was hard for him to to turn that
script.
Now, I will say, even though he spoke perhaps
less about immigrants and didn't attack Latinos
and immigrants as much as he did previously,
his administration wasted no time trying to
to do harm to the communities.
And one of the first things that you will
see president will act when he becomes president,
Joe Biden do is undo much of the harm that
Donald Trump and his administration has done.
Yes.
I want to talk about that next.
So let's get into that.
We've started to see this list of possible
day one executive orders.
We've heard about getting back in the Paris
climate, trans military ban.
Maybe something can be done in terms of the
trade relationship with China via executive
order.
And there's this question mark around DACA
and and dreamers.
What is the day one plan?
What can be done via executive order with
that program?
Quite a bit, actually.
In our new chief of staff, White House Chief
of Staff Ron Klain last week talked about
some of those day one priorities and one of
those.
And it's very important to Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris is protecting dreamers.
So there will be executive action on day one.
And there will also be an immigration bill
that includes, obviously, dreamers and their
families and and a pathway to citizenship,
a roadmap to citizenship for the 11 million
undocumented in this country.
That's that's going to happen right away.
Now, of course, we're going to have to do
a lot of work to get the immigration bill
passed.
But through executive action, there's going
to be a very swift undertaking to protect,
to protect dreamers.
Yeah, I think that if Democrats don't take
the Senate tax reform and the health care
expansion that Joe Biden wants to do, I think
they don't happen.
I do think that because some of these immigration
issues are actually relevant to some Republican
senators, I think that the chance of doing
something on immigration is slightly higher
if even without having the Senate.
But a lot is riding on those races in Georgia,
isn't it?
A lot's riding on those races.
And what I will say is we're hopeful.
And again, you saw Georgia turning blue.
You're seeing a record enthusiasm, a record
vote there, a very diverse electorate.
All of those things bode well.
But I think it's important to remember Joe
Biden has a very distinguished public service
career in the Senate.
He knows how to work across the aisle to get
big things done for America, whether that
was beating the NRA not once but twice, pushing
for the very first climate change legislation
when he was in the Senate that was advocating
and getting past the Violence Against Women
Act.
I mean, the list goes on and on.
He does very well in these situations.
I mean, health care, again, the ACA, another
prime example of him working hard and being
able to to get things done with Democrats
and with Republicans.
And so you can expect four major pieces of
legislation like that for Joe Biden to do
what he does best, which is to try to work
with.
Others to unify not just our country, but
but to unify our government, to tackle these
major challenges.
Yeah, I don't doubt for a second Joe Biden's
ability, willingness and interest to do that.
I just think it's naive to think these Republicans
are going to participate in anything that
doesn't obviously and completely benefit what
what they've laid out as their priorities.
I think the Republican Party has changed dramatically,
but I remain cautiously optimistic.
I think the concern among some in the progressive
left is what would Joe Biden have to compromise
in order to get some of these Republicans
on board?
You know, here's the thing, I.
As a progressive myself, I think what what
we need to remember here is the country is
on this precipice right now.
As Joe Biden talked about this during the
campaign, in our darkest times, our nation
has been able to come together and achieve
the greatest good.
If you look at some of the moments in history,
whether it's coming out of the Great Depression,
whether it's coming out of World War Two,
we're able to come together and do amazing
things.
And I know it sounds naive, but I am optimistic
that we are at one of these moments now where
we're going to have to do we're going to have
to, number one, get this pandemic, the virus
under control.
But then there's an opportunity, and partly
because we have to to rebuild this economy.
And there are a lot of major components that
will go into that, including major investments.
Again, we're going to work with Republicans
and conservatives and progressives and independents
and all Americans to get this done.
But we need to be able to rebuild the economy.
We need to make sure that we get climate change
under control.
And there's ways where we can build millions
of jobs in this country that are better green
jobs.
And so that's part of it.
And that's one of the things we need to do.
And the other is with all of the the racial
justice issues that are now getting a lot
of the attention that they that they deserve,
there's going to be a way to address some
of these systemic racial issues in our country.
Again, even though we're dealing with this
pandemic and having to rebuild this economy,
there are opportunities within that to address
some of these things.
And we're I mean, no, no, no disagreement
from me in terms of the stakes or the priorities,
skepticism, significant skepticism about the
current Republican Party as as a participant
in that.
But we will we will very soon start to see
how it plays out.
We've been speaking with Cristobal Alex, who
is a senior adviser for the Joe Biden for
President campaign.
I really appreciate your time today.
Oh, it was an honor.
Thanks for having me.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.